the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
the title of grand master highly coveted
and sought after since the beginning of
the game
welcome to the third st louis norm
congress
hello everyone i'm grand master dennis
rorsch and i'm here with miss
d'orsadarakshani
so i'm really hoping you're ready for
some grand master and international
master
nahan dorse are you ready
yes let's jump into this we're getting
here yeah let's jump in
exciting moment
yeah so
yeah so first let's take a look at the
standings and then we jump into the
exciting games that's fair so let's
start with the gm section dorset yeah i
guess bellows has win it yeah that's
wanted so
definite huge congratulations to him
it's very nice yeah two one and a half
points ahead of the field
very dominating balaji on two
chris rep got tied with david brodsky
and uh yeah
quite a result i think he's gonna find
that the top three are james
yeah
well uh accidents happen
in gm tournaments
but talking about accidents let's take a
look of what's going on in the im
section while the two leaders are
playing for all the marbles joshua
posuma who has as i heard already
accomplished um his title he actually
clinched the i am title already and
aaron grobinski is nipping
then
close by him and if he wins he wins it
all
wow
how about the we have like four girls
playing here anybody with any potential
well as i can see jennifer you on five
she already drew her game but uh
scoring five points is very respectable
i believe she's winning a lot of rating
points and uh baguette is still playing
and she's facing your friend
antova gabriela and uh so beckham
actually could score five and a half so
she could technically tie for third
now all that said we do to let you know
that you can message us on youtube in a
comment and dorsa will be looking
all day long
yeah i think there's a little comment
about joshua martin michigan is the
strongest player now well who was it
before i mean who was i'm not sure
actually i'm not actually sure about it
either but so let's jump to this big
matchup between grabinski and posuma
because it is for the im section first
place
question from you dennis like
because i feel like whenever i played in
tournaments like i already had like
guaranteed first place or guaranteed
title guaranteed norm i was just like
well
you know that motivation level kind of
reduces a little bit so do you think
that's something that uh aaron can use
against joshua and try to
um because joshua had already scored his
storm and different title and stuff so
do you think um aaron grabinski can use
the fact that joshua could have been a
little bit less motivated than he was
yesterday and win this game
for sure that
plays in into this game but uh on the
other hand posuma is the number one seed
so
that kind of content you know when you
come as number one seed you kind of feel
obligated to win each and every game
that you are having and you're having to
play and as far as i can see
um i have to admit i was joking earlier
that gravinsky likes to put his pieces
in the back row and he might just do the
same thing and voila
he is consistent with his plans
and um if you have time i might even
show his previous game where he
actually
that brought it to the next level
like you imagine all the pieces on the
eighth rank well
well you'll see you'll definitely see
but what do you see here dorsa what do
you think about this position the first
thing i see is see i just had the i
inhaled my lunge so i'm still a little
hungry and i see why it has an extra pot
pawn
[Music]
that extra pawn counts for something
although it's kind of uh
passive like it's very difficult
to use it but i feel like the fact that
so let me ask you like would you prefer
white right now or black um i honestly
i like active play and i really don't
like passively defending pawns even if
they're extra
and for that reason i'm not convinced
that white is better here
okay
because what i can tell
is that uh
yes even though i have the extra one i
can't move that's true like
it could like let's say let's play some
moves let's say bishop e3
knight c4
that's it takes takes that's just a
sample line and even though white is up
a pawn i kind of start liking black here
because there's so many weaknesses and
uh
i guess you shouldn't be worse here as
white because it's an extra pawn still
but um
black is definitely not worse
like i wouldn't be afraid of playing
this as black
we also do have an answer from um the
chat and twitch i believe the username i
can
be
yeah
i i guess that that will be a better
pronunciation i am naturally good at
pronunciations um but it's like i'm
saying that's uh he um they're telling
us like james canty used to be is also
an fm back in 2017
james is also improving yeah like um
he's been playing in charlotte opens and
charlotte tournaments and he's been
improving a lot oh yes patrick i do know
you from youtube wonderful thank you so
actually we have some moves h6 king f1
bishop takes e5
and um
i don't know taking on e5 what do you
think about that dorsa like it dislike
it
would
like a new game instead
i'm
a little confused yeah so i'm asking do
you like this move in general
yeah
good
i mean i like it as
both colors really i don't know i kind
of hate it because this pawn felt weak
to me but when they take it then the
knight on c4 will be a monster
true but i can't pin you
this pawn can be weak i can also defend
this so there is like a potential that
maybe i can give up the b pawn for the a
pawn and
you know let's be honest here you guys
like honesty right
it's still a dead draw there's no way
white is going to win that because your
king will like oh let's you know if
we're
ripe to give some examples let's do it
take take take
say takes
i mean
that's not necessarily the best move but
whenever the king is cut you're either
lost in upon down ending or you're just
drawing a pawn up right like this is
hopeless there's no hope of white ever
winning because i'm just gonna post my
rook behind that pond and if you're not
careful i might just go pac-man mode on
these guys
pac-man that's all nice okay i i can't
help but notice uh i'm seeing in the the
leaches chat that there is a little bit
of a
confusion slash question going on about
the result of julian's game yeah uh that
game um
what i heard that julian got sick so
that's why the game ended the way it did
um so
let's take a look i so for now i feel
that this is roughly even so
if you had to put money would you put
money on draw on this one
okay that that's that's it okay that
that's
that's a good
good question there
would i
would i put money
i think i wouldn't put money because
black can still mess it up
a little bit but
would you
depending on the move it just made i saw
he just wrote something down yeah it was
knight c4
um
i mean i wouldn't put money in it yet
but i i'd still be confident that the
draw is very likely yeah i can't receive
a good way white can improve the
position but at the same time i don't
really see any way for black to actually
you know use the
yeah i mean the thing is that uh
eventually if somehow wait so maybe
that's the point of postuma that i could
go knight b6 and go on id5
all right so i
heard that there are some genius moves
in the evan park game
so let's see
i think that's the other section it's
the other section so let me maybe go to
the other tabs yeah i don't think it's
there let me
um
i don't think wait
oh it's going to be here how are these
kids doing it let me see
oh we got it right yay
so oh no it's the wrong one just a
minute it's just dojo live oh yeah thank
you so much for the ray that's so sweet
oh yeah so there is this crazy crazy
position
in the even park game and then the
second to first
count yeah
okay there's a whole lady
whole lady chilling there b3 okay this
must be mate isn't this mate in three
i mean i'm a little
surprised if it isn't yeah yeah it's
check
here check checkmate yeah also hello to
chess dojo people
and karo people so check here here and
it's mate
that's i see that so question how where
does that leave
um balaji because he was balaji um
i think he had
six yeah we might need the standings if
we could that'd be this game was wild
but that also kind of wraps up the gm
section
yeah so meanwhile let's just go back and
see what happened here
so white actually had a big attack
earlier on but uh somehow managed to
squander it
and i don't like that king in the middle
of the board no it's not not a lot of
fun but we've got standings that means
balaji
with this loss
he's going to
be on five and a half and still actually
he manages to stay on two because all
the other games are finished also
just because i'm in a hunt for titles i
see more
to stuff understandings we have gm but
on the
leeches we have i am
yeah but i think those are the ones to
be trusted ah so he's already made it
yeah but um
yeah it's
it's not pleasant never pleasant
especially when you have such a great
position early on it's a nice attack but
so let's see
i don't know
and boom rook takes c4
gives up the whole lady for some fun
well so f truck takes e4 wasn't played
well otherwise the queen is trapped
the queen can't go here because i
captured you
big time
and that's also defended so
basically the only move but a cool only
move yeah so like i'm trying to circle
back and see like when did um evan park
make that decision oh could be fun if
you get him for an interview yeah it'd
be amazing to have him for an interview
so
yeah we're thinking the same thing here
so takes
rook
what uh yeah rook d4 check yeah
king c3
can you see two whoa
this is very spicy and i guess if you go
here knight check and bye bye
we take everything but yeah i mean i
feel like at that point since you're
losing so much material yeah but let's
let's see the count there's a single a
single piece chat a single piece for the
queen it's very rare that it's actually
winning
that's well almost never happens well
i'm like i feel like he knew the attack
i mean he knew that he was
um setting you know self-trapping his
queen
for that attack
which hopefully we can confirm but i
mean that but uh i mean how could you
tell that the attack is going to be good
you just count the attackers and the
defenders one defender versus four
so that's the reason and these are just
uh spectators on the other side of the
board they're chilling
they're having some nice picnic here
but meanwhile you know you just get
mated yeah king b3
check and yeah if even if you go to the
d file anywhere you go to d2 d1 doesn't
matter you get checked and there she
goes
[Music]
here
check
and bishop ct is a sweet little move
quiet moves yeah these quiet moves make
or break all these games and if you
really want to be a super gm go for the
silent moves
i'm probably trying
i'm probably trying multiple uh
questions in there that you might not
know the answer for sure but so evan
park would this win
yeah
does he cost 2 400
for the first time that is a good
question we're going to ask him nice and
the other question i would like to know
is norm situation in norm situation
that's not the gm norm so uh the i am
norm so we're going to go back to the i
am norm and uh
i im section and once evan is back yeah
we'll uh pop back here
so
let me
pull it up
hmm
and look at the costume game
can we go for my friend yeah sure thank
you my current potential teammate future
potential team
the future and the past
coming together so let's take a look at
the game between uh antova gabriela and
tokyo nova goldberg begging so let's
take a look
um
i like the pond count for white that's a
ton of pawns
and we've got another lady in the chat
talia good to see you and if you guys
don't know her
she is also one of impossible impossible
but it's true she is part of the saint
louis chess club and also a streamer so
do check out talithali26 my teammate
well my slew teammates yes so
well this looks very very pleasant for
white that that looks like a juicy pawn
structure
it's very difficult to get to that e
pawn
her time though but her time but that
unfortunately isn't surprising because
she hasn't been having issues with time
trouble these days and uh
yeah
i wouldn't want to be a betting man in
this game either even though
i do think gabby should be
winning objectively
say i like that that game is taking her
time like yeah but she's not spending
too much time
yeah ruxia she is trying to set up some
trickies and pushing
uh gabby to come up with
an idea maybe queen a7 is actually not
that bad oh i wonder if uh
bad game is up for some nasty tricky two
and just say you could do that yes and
that is something that she should do
because you need to get some time
or queen a i like queen a7
because it sort of forces uh begging
back yeah
i don't know for some reason i am a bit
skeptical of her going king a2
because that's just not her style she
likes to be concrete
i think english is more my style i'm
sort of like sit there smiling your face
and be like hey
well it's fair and
that's probably something very much in
common with you and carlson that sounds
beautiful it's a great comparison thank
you you're welcome but it's true i mean
he'd play king a2 here and then a
heartbeat like i mean i see she's
touching something she
she took the pawn
but
i don't think this is necessarily bad so
rook c1 rook takes queen takes you hide
so rook c1 takes takes i can hide and i
don't see any tricks
so why takes rook takes so it's good
it's a good move but it could be a
little risky because if you miscalculate
well yeah that's what i was thinking too
but
huh so queen after you just take this
yeah
rook takes d3 just knight takes d3
yeah and rook takes knight takes
then maybe rook to it but no there's
okay so takes takes you know when you're
trying to get some counterweight doesn't
mean you just try to get something
it's just like when you didn't have
lunch you tried to eat something
no no no i still went for a pokedoke
yeah
so if queen b7 their screen takes e4 and
i yeah this is on the board i do
anticipate queen h3 happening because
you know if you don't have anything else
you want to create some sort of
counterplay
so it takes
hmm
wait why is back him down three pawns
because gabby
took them all
uh from what i know she was staying with
me for a few nights and
we woke up late today so we couldn't get
proper breakfast so i'm assuming she's
hungry in this game
okay
so hunger is a big motivator in that
room i presume so here then there's
taste
okay so she's trying to play for
pressure
um queen b7 i still want to say king a2
i just want to move that king oh well
yeah queen a2 queen e2
yeah that's it's actually annoying
queen b7 the only problem that that
could be tick tick and this is just a
perpetual
she's gonna move
she's gotta move well queen c4 maybe
queen ticks
or queen e2 still maybe uh
no but then i can go queen b3 i can just
go back and just defend it then maybe
get another no but knight c6 knight oh
there's e7 check nevermind
yeah there's that check that sneaky
check
yeah i think let's see for queen b3
might be yeah but that's why i agree
with you it wasn't such a great idea to
take on d3 no
oh she was queen c4 yeah
yeah i mean
i think you're right doris said that
taking on d3 might be objectively good
but not in this situation where
you know you have to be extra precise
not to drop something
so queen e2
queen b3
and i assume maybe she will just go king
h7 now i would just try to go
oh uh
i'm trying to see when the knight f2
maybe
knight f2 take take queen e1 or maybe
even takes done yeah so here
it should work
depending on c8
rooks
queen f1
uh d4
yeah queen e4 checking a2
yeah that still works
um
so here but i presume that uh black
would do this i think bagan would take
here and just try to go for this one and
again this is what we've been talking
about this is she made the move what
does she do so it's like queen c5 and uh
queen e2 was played
okay well queenie is actually i don't
like this movie because it gives up the
h3 attack yeah i mean that was probably
the biggest hope for
begging so queen b3
king h7 and i guess that's what they're
banking on
i do it definitely think both of them
are playing for a win now
huh
um but again aren't we a bit tangled
here like she played the queen b3
thank you thank you for the video
adjustment
yeah i'm not sure though how she's going
to wait knight f2 is still works
okay maybe king a2 too just to get that
so maybe she'll have to go rook d5 so
well you can still go night after
mistake and now you have the queen
around so there's no yeah checks
uh-huh but if she gets knight f2n like
this
okay
c8
the knight is still awkward that's the
problem the knight is still very awkward
here
all right
queen b6
yeah this is still messy that's why i'm
saying king a2 like you should have that
king on it too
no like before now you move the knight
so you do the kanga too so the knight
moves then you can do like queen b7 yeah
so queen f3 was played
cute pin king a2 oh
okay
[Music]
um yeah probably that still wins
yeah so this is what dorset is talking
about king a2 captures knight f2 it's a
double attack
always double attack
it's the moral of the story
takes takes
and i mean the night will be back in due
time this is winning
i have no doubts about like if this is
not winning
come on your title gotta go come on
yes like what the heck
that must be winning like there's no no
way this lone horsey is going to stop
all those
future ladies can't stop them ladies
i used to call them baby queens
so king a2 was played finally
she did it she didn't oh my gosh she's
hearing my voice good job gabby can you
king k2 and that's actually one of the
best ways of playing in a good position
defend everything and then just go from
there take away opponents checkability
yeah
don't let them check you
don't let them check on you i'll take
soon here
king age seven
i guess you could still do this cool
night after i kind of like your move
this this one's kind of nice yeah
because
fun night of today yeah it's just uh
this is well defended if you trade i
take takes i take here
so
beg him is in some trouble but gabby's
still very low on time it's 30 seconds
that's not necessarily enough oh we want
to hear a small fun fact
they're both going to be playing in
chicago tournaments in
i think they're flying at tomorrow oh
okay
yeah so it's
flying people playing against each other
oh yes king a2 i guess a move was played
rook d4 so exactly of what bad game is
doing she says
knife you go here i whoop i take you
that's fair so that's uh her plan that's
why she played rookie can i buy queen c3
it seems legal to me thank you queen c3
here
probably there's a queen d5 check though
takes takes so
yeah
you're being very crafty today doris are
you being very i'm trying my best a4
a4 is that make or break kind of move
it's either really good or really not
good
however
so let's say knight d5 although okay
let's try it and d5
yeah e7 i think e7 is just very good
because then you just
do you flip
flip the script on your opponent and now
you're probably just promoting
and so
bagging actually doesn't have these
trickies and that's why it's good to
have lots of pawns because in this case
it doesn't matter if you lose the piece
who cares you just promote yeah
so knight d5 doesn't work
but then what could she do probably
queen e4 just to
kill
it's not a dog it's a king
queen e4
i probably have knight c5 i think but
but
fair
you know respect the king the respect
the king
queen c6
uh oh queen c6h
knight b4 yeah
yeah that looks good
so if she like this looks scary right
queen a ate them and i guess i can't go
anywhere oh we're still not before
yeah you can still go before true
so apparently there's no well i guess
maybe this is the moment for begging not
to do anything
and just wait for 485
yeah wait for gabby to do something
because for the moment she's holding
everything
together perfectly
like king h7 because
anything we came up with dorsa refuted
us so
i think one thing that i'm kind of like
i i think maybe instead of a4 how about
queen c2 instead of i mean c2 with the
plan or you instead of a4 so like knight
to my idea is knight f2
ah okay
yeah that makes sense yeah a4 is a
little
dicey i don't necessarily like it it's
just i have to agree too the king is
just getting a little bit exposed
probably queen c like oh she's about to
do king h7 yep did she
probably she i would assume she did yep
and that's a very very good move by
begging just saying hey i don't really
have a good move but do you
and that's a tough question when you
have 20 seconds quincy too
yeah quincy to be nice and even if they
check at least you could go to a better
square and did you do it did you do it i
can't sing and uh well we'll see it
eventually so queen c to make sense or
even king b1 like you don't need to do
anything yet
rook d2 yeah rook dit is not the
greatest because the rook is undefended
now
queen takes h3 as possible
because there are no more night moves
well
ladies and gentle people
there could be some twists and turns in
common
i gotta have a chat with gabby so take
she's still her captain still her
captain
so queen eight maybe queen e3 but then
queen e3
look here
yeah i don't think that this is like
crystal clear anymore i think that this
is just complicated and uh
yeah gabriella's clock is a big factor
here oh yes
and um
[Music]
there's no doubt that this
is this for much longer let's take a
break from it all right so we're gonna
take a little break break from um i'm
gonna have a little tea that's a break
maybe let's go back to the erin joshua
game you know let's go back to the
joshua game and
thank goodness dorsa scared me
otherwise i would have become a betting
man and that would have been sad
apparently black is actually
yeah that pawn that
that d-pawn that is gone and black has a
majority on the king's side and these
pieces are really bad
now we're gonna go and see what happened
so we left it off over here
black play knight c4 rook c5 and rook c5
is sort of
assuming that he's better but
objectively can tell that he's not
better
he's barely even and should try to just
stabilize rook c5 i think was slightly
inaccurate
trades trades here rook c5 and now
you're not even up a pawn and you have a
terrible structure
and you'll never really even going to be
able to create a good passer and this
knight is just so much better than this
bishop yeah that's a big monster
you know what let's look at this game
from black's perspective
oh you want a black perspective
here you go thank you thank you
so roxy3 f5 and it also makes sense
because actually postsuma is half a
point ahead of aaron so if he wins or
draws
he is the undisputed champion of the im
section so f5 takes six oh speaking of
champions and stuff it would be nice to
see that the the good dollar bills money
prizes at some point again so
hopefully we're gonna get uh some
material on that in a bit but let's
see yeah we've got the prizes so let's
take a look at it
so first place is bella's right yeah
first is for baloch yes
so he's pocketed to two grand good for
him yeah congratulations 15k for
50.
why not 15. that'd be nice that'd be
amazing
it's a 1500
it is actually 1500 for balaji and it's
sort of a consolation prize for him
after that game yeah even with the loss
he managed to yeah
like he had a great tournament and
um he would have had an even better one
if he would have fell victim to that
beautiful attack oh my god that was such
a cool you know what i'm there's a
grandmaster choice class tonight i think
i'll go over that game a little it was
just such a fun yeah it was
quite a fascinating
game
it's worth a look but let's now take a
look at the iron section shall we
and in the im section so the game that
we're watching there between aaron and
joshua they're fighting over the two
will get 1200 who will get yeah
yeah number one at number two
and right now it does feel
a little bit more likely
that um grabinsky isn't going to grab
the 1200 oh look at that face
i think he knows it too i don't know
that that look
well some people speak when they look
like they have very good nonverbal cues
that look like is drawing coming it's
just like a sad face was it a sad face
okay
yeah i mean i felt like okay knight
takes v2 is likely to happen
i think he knows knight takes v2 and
then
you're not going to win this game once
this happens
you may still lose it probably not
but you're definitely not going to win
it and that's good enough for joshua
yeah
so i think a great tournament yeah
fantastic tournament and uh
been scoring some very nice wins
especially in durati
so i think this
once once he
flicks that on the board
i have no doubt we're gonna have a
champion
that will be wonderful and just to
clarify no chance for uh playoffs
well
yeah that is correct i mean joshua is
half a point ahead so oh yeah and
they're playing each other sadly there
are no potentials for playoffs it would
have been fun to sit here and talk about
oh armageddon ah five seconds left
yeah but i'm afraid that's not gonna
happen this time
so talking about armageddon and five
seconds let's just go back to the
gabriella game
and uh doris's dreams sometimes come
true
but maybe this wasn't her dream because
after check
i don't know like king e2 obviously is
not five
yeah knight c5 has to be played night
and it was
that king is making a walk but it's not
a king walk you want to have
yeah this is
madness now and i don't like
what uh gabriella is doing rook c4 maybe
i don't know rook c4 knight a5 rook
takes d4 actually that might work
because so here all i know is that i
don't like it
well it already it's past the time that
you don't like it you have to make it
work somehow
you don't have time to panic anymore
okay it's that it's that kind of
situation yeah here then you can take
here
yeah you just have to be cold-blooded
here but it's difficult it's very
difficult like she played rook c3 hmm if
she had half hour i would i would have
you know yeah that'd be a confident win
but
yeah with the king dancing around
on the kingston he can come back but
then knight is going to be really yes it
really doesn't have any it doesn't
really have a good square so knight b4
what would you do if that game will play
knight b4
also this is a question for all of you
watching what would you do if black will
play knight b4 here okay and you have to
think about one minute on the clock well
roxy what are those nasty rook d3s that
i'm not going to think
and meanwhile we've got a resultant paul
chambers drew
versus alice lee well i'll be honest
with you i take here
ah because yes
it might not be anything like might not
be winning on the spot
but there's zero chance i'm to ever lose
to a single queen okay that's fair
actually your rook is a feeling
yeah actually yeah i like this and i
mean clearly this position isn't for the
single ladies
so rook d1
which is nasty um
bad game is trying to ambush gabby's
king from behind that's not nice well
king a2 must be played king a2 rook d4
her c4 maybe
yeah
but that's kind of the question if she's
going to spot rook c4 or not
so king a2 queen d4 rook c4
here queen d4 rook c4
i would mentally scream for 20 seconds
yeah i i have a feeling that might be
going on
yeah
um
you know you really just have to be
ice cold in these situations and just
try to focus on the moves not forget
your internal dialogue it's not going to
help here
you start talking to yourself you're
already flagging somewhere
so here yeah i think well actually no
you can't go there because you have to
stop this idea yeah
knight a6 is way too scary to be true
what about knight d3 ah
well
knight b4 no the problem is that uh i
still have a queen
and uh i don't think this is enough for
white yeah not
for sure not for enough for a win wait
maybe e7
knight c5 unlucky for you at least i
mean probably you can't draw wait no you
can't
you can't even draw queen f7 okay but i
perpetually
i mean maybe it's time to just call it
soon
or you know hope to find this idea of
rook c4 which is not easy if you're not
sure that's ea tonight that would have
been fun yay night oh that's cool let's
uh put that on the board
so knight d3 take six here e7 knight c5
e8 knight
i'm in
that's very cool
um
the knight is a little clumsy there
though so even after queen e7 i'm not
sure
queen
because you go there i check like again
all your pieces are going for a vacation
or maybe it couldn't be four that's what
you said
yeah you're feeling very penny today
yeah
you're just
trying
to inside drama on the board
yeah this one is actually pretty nice
takes away all those critical squares
yacking e2 and beckham is still thinking
so i presume she played rook d4
no played queen d4 so i think she's
clearly playing for a win i'm not sure
that's the right thing to do but maybe
she noticed that rook c4 works and she
wanted to look for something else so
she's trying to go cheap trick queen g1
rookie one checkmate well that's not
cheap trick that's nasty
well can i just play rook d3 now
rook d3
check well tick tick yeah you lose the
knight that's the problem
on queen c4 that's a great move trying
to shoo the rival lady away from his
majesty in farsida
yeah
okay
get out okay so queen c4 the king is
trying to escape via the escape route
but i don't know about it
king b3 yeah but there might be some
welcome
or not so welcome checks might be three
i agree with your oofs but
yeah
i guess queen well this is hanging so
you gotta move
that
knight e5
queen b4
or queen e2 we need to
oh and
endorses on fire today
oh i had good lunch ah the lunch yeah
it's the pokey it's the pokey
man that was expensive
but it turns out to be worth it yeah
right i'm seeing good news can i go
about playing
yeah so g5 yeah this this is very good
and
the reason i'm so happy about it because
it defends everything and sets up some
tricky tricky checkmates on the back
rank so
it's kind of what the doctor would
prescribe
nice one this is very very smooth thank
you thank you
i'm going to use that since i'm the
stream of strong nylon yeah so queen e2
and unfortunately for black
the knight cannot really come back
yeah so queen c4 um
it's five minutes for begging so
we're going down the wire
in this one
um
yeah look at look at beckham she's in
full tank
and i see i see gabby in the zone as
well
i feel like they're but they're like
they're both brains are
growing new new runs yeah
hopefully fall and not losing neurons
all right this is queen g1 is coming ah
expected that one might be through that
b3 not b3 plate plate i mean you really
can't do anything else i mean she might
go king by three i mean you don't want
to
did she do it did she do it
killing me i have a feeling that dorsa
is way more nervous than the two players
playing look she's still spending the
ninth on my couch so that's fair that's
fair you want to be supportive i need to
know if i'm breaking open tequila or
coffee i see so high b3 uh
for sure a great move
ray robson in this said
and if i could speak english i would
have said ray robson said five head and
indeed and b3 is the right move and the
best move in the position
so far so good that's all i can say and
really i think the question will be if
she's gonna find queenie too if she
finds queenie two i go eighty versus
twenty percent that she's gonna win
queen two is classic dorset style you
look into upon his soul you see what
they want you take it away
i mean and that sounds more like
dorsa playing more tall combat but
yeah you don't want to see that
i'm telling you that i've never played i
should actually yeah but that sounds
scary but that that
i'm imagining it just imagining it hurts
me all right so 95 queen e2 that looks
really good and
maybe there then there's a5 so knight e5
queen e2
here a5 a4
i want to go back and just yeah but
that's the thing pawn scan
can't move backwards actually that's one
of the variants i want to develop where
you can move pawns backwards
you can't you can't move you can't
promote your own pawn of course but you
could move your palm backwards okay tell
me a little bit more about this magical
realm so really it's chess it's the same
thing but from a4 you could go back to
a3 or f5 to f4 and it's not difficult
but imagine that all those drawn pawn
endings are winning now
okay
so in fact i might have just solved
chess and uh
wanting more decisive games
you fixed the problem of draws yeah i
did but like i said it to everyone i
said yeah yeah yeah we're not going to
listen
but i i'm actually honest that's
probably that'll be a new challenge for
the the top hundred people who just keep
playing each other and draw yeah i mean
i'd be actually excited maybe leeches
is hearing us it'd be awesome to have
that uh very variant on we have moves we
have moves you've got moves
rook d6 queen c5 queen c5 is nice
if you can get those yeah so qc5
attacking the rook queen
a2 or queen d1 would you still want to
go on queen takes c6 and thursday extra
tanks or probably yes
i think that all these super gm's will
say i take you and you safa i just
over defend myself whatever you do i
don't care
sooner or later you're going to be the
one flagging and i'm going to be
promoting
so queen d1 because
it's still tricky
i don't like i guess just like
yeah it's a decent practical decision
because you can never lose anymore
because
um
a5 maybe
probably she's to go for a five minutes
we should just play queen b5
b5 okay
still
very dicey
a little wow that's a good idea for a
variant would make middle games really
intense no it's exciting because it's
it's basically chess but maybe it will
be like no pawn backwards in the first
like 30 minutes yeah you could do that
like after move 40. yeah you have that
and that's completely fine yeah it's
backwards chess that's how i called it
but i don't know
um
the first person excited about it was
doorstone
i am like a little excited these pawns
are nasty i would just want that pawn to
come back come back home yeah like i'd
love to play a3 as well like i go e3 and
i go like now what you're going to do
now what you're going to do
yes so takes
takes e7 here
knight a5
too complicated
what no no no no that's called
simplifying dorsa
this is an extra night on the board last
night's on the board well what about
that knight
here
and well there's rook see it yeah so
that maybe you have a point and id4 here
knight e6 yeah i don't want to give it
up you don't want to give anything
no is this better is this better now
are you happy now
i don't like king i honestly don't like
this how about some instead of like king
a3 how was like 95
am i
yeah
maybe night yeah it's actually difficult
i kind of still kind of like this
because takes and something it's a
little murky yeah although i get your
you know what i really want to go
queenie to but now i can't because of my
b4
wait maybe we could do it though because
it's a check and i can just i like looks
scary but how are you gonna make me like
i have that protected that's true um
and if i ever get g5 and you're lost
let's say knight d5 i go here it takes
g5 is paying that much attention to the
king side
yeah i mean that's actually the trick of
chess even if you're winning you can
still play on both sides
so yeah
maybe mine is like rook c6 is a bit too
adventurous but i've won this but again
i mean credit to beg him like she always
takes away all these rules
really nice centralization she's playing
more so yeah in my style yeah i mean
it's very important to centralize and
just to over defend
and even though gabby is over defending
she's not taking center squares
queen c5
looks similar but then the queen was
here
okay
wait queen c5 is nice
you can't move to rook because we go
gobble gobble
queen f4
and then
five
knight e5 i'm still gonna love that man
i mean i get it but it also looks
you could do it though
95 because that doesn't work because i
take
wait
it might work
that's fine that's what i'm saying that
once you remove your defender even
though you have the right intentions
you're gonna get punished
mate
so that's
that's why you should never really move
defenders
okay she moved
i presume she played queen b5
or a5
she played queen b5 yep
so i guess queen e4 you could still just
go a5
i see nothing wrong with that either
it's a little risky but what is black
going to do
it's not
i'm not sure like there's anything going
on are they trying to professional
um
who's trying to perpetual you just
played queen e4
yeah i mean of course he'd be happy for
him to draw i mean she's down 50 pawns
i'd love to draw in this case
but i think you can go a5 like i know
it's a little scary but i mean it's all
she goes queen c4
hmm
[Music]
back
then queen c5 but we've been there
before then
so queen c4
queenie i like queen b1
yeah that's a that's a cute
cute way of outing that lady
see you're trying to mess around with my
king get trapped
in c4 i presume yeah queen h1
queen h1 a5 maybe
yeah this is scary legit scary
and uh
this is that typical like just bring the
king back to a2 the king was fine
the reason people love the najdorf that
you get a position like this without the
e pawn with black
so
it's the extra stress for white minus
being lost
so a5
oh then there's knight a5
queen of four
wait
wait no that doesn't work because i have
queen a2 yeah i saw that yeah otherwise
this would still work and in fact be
winning
um
here here
here here
blade queen f4 okay that's a great move
so finally gabby is understanding that
hey hey girl
i've got
some
some stuff going on on the king side
how you doing here buddy
on h7 and g5 is
should be played but i go g5 i think i
think queen f4 was the big move
for gabby and that might be the clincher
i go 90 10 by now i go 90 versus 10.
let me write that down
all right i stand by like this queen f4
seems like also it's attacking the rook
and g5
and there's
like you might have a check but that's
all
she has
queen d1 or rook i guess rook d1
is the best you could do
trying to do that
so take take take king v1 you could look
c1 yeah yeah c1 very good very good move
by
gabby and that's that's how you're
supposed to play just keep the control
of the position don't do anything
spectacular and then you're gonna win
and sadly for begging well
even though you might be begging for
that h pawn the c6 knight might just
fall on this game over
did you put big him and begin i might
have
i might have
but
that was a good one nice job
i believe
ryman is no crime
but okay
yeah i think rook c1 and now g5 is in
common and uh
yeah i don't really need that g5 anymore
if i can get the rooks off the board i'm
happy well but if you get g5 in its
i'm gonna game those other three pawns
who cares about g5 well you know you can
win
an hour earlier
which is nice
so
yeah roxy won and they think this is
after biggie makes her move let's go
back and take a look at the um aaron
joshua game and i'm also really curious
if we're gonna have any interviews
well i guess we might have after these
games that's fair
because there's a bunch of people i wish
we could interview well but i won't be
here for that oh
well you could
you want me to stand behind the door and
just
sign in my
questions so rook c1 meanwhile that
other position the iran and posthumous
um let's stick to this game i think this
is still very exciting two minutes for
begging and
uh yeah you could see just look at the
non-verbals she took it look at the
non-verbals beckham is clearly not happy
with what she sees
yeah she did
she had like less pawns forever
yeah and she still was very tricky up
till the end
yesterday and queen c5
i mean
literally what else are you going to do
i don't know but there's always chances
of
i mean yeah chances are everywhere but
queen of
c3
i just want to go which block you oh
well i could go a5 no
oh yeah question won't work
you might want to promote a queen you
know one queen
at least on the chessboard one queen is
never enough no e7
queen e4 was played
um
i still kind of like queen c5 just
centralized
there's no reason not to do that i
completely agree and just take away all
the fun
from your opponent and then just look
for a new princess
you know the the queen is already on the
board
can only be a princess not necessarily
true
that
on a4 could be a baby queen until it's
like on a7 then it's about to get to the
coronation it could be a new empress who
knows yeah
true true
it could become a baby queen
all right so queen c5 is well she played
queen c3 which is fine okay and over
defending the h pawn although i just
like grabbing a lot of space the more
space the better and you could also draw
a house in that case
i mean now we still want to push that a
pawn maybe knight
c5
c5
yeah i mean literally everything is near
winning for
white
however how do you like knight c5 97
knight f8 check
it's pretty
but i don't really see the point and
also you leave your king a little bit
vulnerable and that's actually when you
sort of mess up your game
you're winning but you're just taking an
extra adventure it's just like you're
playing skyrim and instead of just going
with the main story you're just going
for side quests
no
you you don't like side quests i love
you oh your life's okay
i'll live for side questions
and i went away for a bit seems like
white is still winning though well she's
more winning than she was before
and i'm pretty sure gabby is happier
than like
15 moves ago
50 15 oh
so king g8 and this move already shows
that she was super scared of knight f8
so i don't know i guess we can just push
the pawn i still kind of like knight c5
yeah she played a5 she listens
she's that's the right thing to do push
yourself is where the clock advantage is
basically gone
yeah no more side quests
only the main quest
help the baby queen
hail a little bit hail to hail the baby
queen
so the apon is making a dash for it
but i don't know if you can use super
dash yet you may need that question
royal support
on the side
and uh 95. let's see i don't like
nightsticks i really don't like that
why
why like oh why not look
the reason we have guardian pawns around
the king so it doesn't feel naked on the
board
once the substitute leaves it's totally
inappropriate
so we might want to have it but if not
c5 queen h1 b3
okay
but why do you want to self-made
yourself i'm not self-managing my queen
is not saying three
okay
so you're on the quest of promoting
don't take more side quests i want two
baby queens
i get it but you know the witcher can do
that
can take as many quests as he likes
we're not
i'm not the witcher sadly oh henry
cavill oh yeah that's true
you know if you're henry cavill you
could do anything but here i'd just go
queen c5 and just chill
are all players rooms usa well the ones
i know are not
no these two are from usa
all right we're winning here this is
completely winning like this is
completely winning for gabby
what e7 you could also just check an e7
i mean
okay
like this is the one i don't complain
i'm trying to do
trying not to lose yeah she actually
found chick
and now you seven is coming yeah he's
listening to you very deeply
i mean
she knows who to listen to
i mean e7 is coming knight c4 boom boom
and then baby queen
i mean this time with multiple pieces
you might have a twin
baby queen
baby queens
yeah
king 87
she's going to play e7
push the other baby i'm trying man
i think she's going to play e7 i think
she sees that so let's touch it oh
nice
and the e pawn is going
it's almost ready for the coronation but
i think
almost just almost i think knight c4 may
happen or resignation i guess maybe um i
think resignation is coming i feel like
she's about to start
big game seems like she's accepting it
yeah i think she's accepting it
that is quite a nice
game by gabby
um after such a rough event and i'll be
honest with you she wasn't playing badly
it was mostly her time yeah it was yeah
it was her time control there are so
many games that i was like oh she's got
this yeah this is such a pretty position
but yeah and um
as soon as she's going to be playing in
tournaments with time controls with
extra 30 minutes
she's going to gain a lot of ratings
she she's going to definitely gain it
back
but she can even gain more because her
quality of play might have like i think
knight c4 was but yeah
knight c4 was played
wow
i guess that's that's the last move she
took it she took it
so it takes
meanwhile
according to gm ray robson if we can
um trust the source
um hello
they're still playing a dead draw end
game and uh i don't know about you dorsa
i trust him so i presume
that rook ending we saw look kind of
drawish and we may go back if this game
ends but for now should be ending very
soon yeah but you know we've been
following through and they just
won't stop
i think they're shaking hands in a
minute
because queen takes c4 and i think she
took queen takes e7
she did take
whoa
so she's not giving up yet all right so
queen b4 goal queen c5
knight c5
you've got a fixation with that 195 move
i can't clearly tell but hey it's not an
unhealthy one
slightly unhealthy but not completely
unhealthy
been before
i'm
it's funny to me dorsal loves knight c5
b4 b5 it's time it's time to push those
baby queens yeah but
they're there to protect their guardian
pawns because they're duty but it's just
a solo queen i can just protect it with
my solo queen so my point is if i can i
mean we can get a dual queen now clear
but my point was like if knights go c5
we push the b pawn and then we can bring
the knights back hold the queen on c3 so
they can't check us and we can just go
la la la la a6
i can't tell you're trying to
win it in style
queen c yeah i don't like queen c3
though because
it's not bad though it's just over
defending
but sooner or later why not just
go and push the pawn i agree
green f1
um
all right all right all right let's see
five
ah queen i won
booking v4
i'm not scared of your lone queen
loan queens can't
checkmate i know and i didn't design
this game so don't blame me
so knight c5 and even though that queen
is gonna harass the ruler it's not gonna
be enough
dorsal just tell that is they guard the
king perfectly fine if the king is on a7
i mean that's also true if white makes
walk the king in an
old-fashioned manner put it on a7
yeah but i still like what uh gabby is
doing and she's just doing much yeah now
she's doing the right thing before she's
like well let's have fun and just risk
the king's life but now she's like okay
i feel feel safe now
queen b5
all right
some night movies too excited no not c5
yeah knight c5 is actually great yeah
and id4 is actually bad oop
check check i know
so bad game is tricky bag him
between b5 i mean one minute knight c5
whoa
uh she resigned
and
there that's all she wrote knight c5 is
on the board and
quite a nice game by
gabby yeah i'm glad she finally like
nice i think uh the results out of it it
was so nice she died i think it didn't
have a bad tournament yeah no becky was
playing well too
gabby scored less than
beg him did
but i
honestly when i was looking at the games
objectively they were doing well in this
field
but as i said before for gabby it really
had to do with uh time trouble yeah i
completely agree and uh if she gets
quicker or like plays quicker in the
opening
i think
she's gonna gain
tons of rating points 50 or even more
it could be fun no gabby is definitely
oh my god her face she's still exhausted
yeah gabby is happy exhausted slash the
tournament is over but we definitely
want to hear from her if possible
so let's go to this game
where
my eyes
where there's
very few pieces left where are the pawns
no pawns left
but the funny thing is if any of the
sides loses something they could still
win
so
maybe wait is black trying to wait roxy
to check ah that you can still block
just go rook c5
but for example
this is a draw but
we are going to enjoy
so even though
dorset wouldn't have a tie break to
enjoy she could enjoy a rook bishop
versus rook ending that's totally fair i
would enjoy that
it's possible
so
so far it's still very much even
although one minute on each side
there could be a blunder here or there
but
meanwhile
royalty has snuck in the studio
rook c2 rugby five rookie seven okay
so who's trying to lose here dorsa
trying to lose man that's a hard one
i don't know which side is trying to
lose here my question can we go back and
see
how many pawns
hello hello
yeah so you want me to switch out or do
you want to switch out doors
i have some deep questions to ask
and you can let us know about that
totally fair
and if you message we'll know so
rookie 7 knight f6
um we'll be happy to have
gabby join in a minute
knight f6 and uh
yeah
let's be straight up and honest
this is still very much drawish
um
it's funny what happened on the screen
so
it says king d3 king e5 king e4
checkmate now that's a checkmate i've
never seen before
and i'm a little bit uh suspicious that
that's probably not
probably not what happened but that just
means that joshua wins
the grand master section
with
this draw in a clear first
place i am section my bad the i am
section although possum i've been
cruising so much that uh i'm not
surprised to see him next time in the gm
section
but in any case we have a guest here
and her name is
gabriela antova good to have you hi
so
how did this game go what how did you
uh
get ready for this game
well the game it was just wild like i've
been having like a terrible event i was
on two out of eight
and to be fair
i really didn't want to go to the round
i was like this is gonna be even more
pain
so
what happened in the game i didn't
expect that opening
so um she had played some games in the
rogozin
like the
um
quinzindian but i did not see this
coming so usually i didn't go for e4
here but
i wasn't sure what she had prepared so i
was like i will try to deviate and i
know that is the best move just i wasn't
very up to date on my theory
so basically
i just went for it oh okay
i guess beckham might be the player
although i'm not that familiar with her
style that she plays
more or less everything
yes she has a very diverse repertoire
well that's the pc way to put it yes
yeah e4 bishop v4 check and i've seen
this one before um this have been a big
favorite
of i believe of the mavericks of chess i
see rapport in the list over there takes
take screen takes d5 and that has been
their pet line i don't know were you
familiar with this d5 idea um i was
aware of the idea but
i didn't really feel comfortable with
the position
um
because i thought that she would get
initiative pretty fast like after
uh takes takes e5 c5 mm-hmm
or yeah 97
and
i really wasn't sure how to put my
pieces because um
yeah so um
because i don't know it's obvious that i
don't have an advantage
but i thought it might get unpleasant
pretty quickly if i don't play
accurately
and i don't think i did
yeah i mean
this is a very tricky position it
actually feels a bit more like the f3
nemzos where you get a huge center and
you're being attacked yeah but the thing
is i don't play it any eggs i know that
that's that's the pain of it all and
that's actually the benefit of beckham's
style that she could
mix it up and get chances that otherwise
you wouldn't
so knight c3 and i mean i guess most
people would go f4 but bishop d3 makes
sense as well
trying to
just put the knight here and just over
defend all those squares
here everywhere surprised that there is
actually a game in this position no i
mean
you're playing very logical moves um and
even though i don't blame you for
spending time here because you were not
too familiar but you're just doing the
right thing uh i think that what
happened i was spending so much time
because it built a pressure
i really didn't want to lose again okay
so i was very insecure about what i was
doing so she surprised me in the opening
which didn't help either
so i wasn't very comfortable like at all
i mean i don't blame you like it's very
scary sometimes just to feel and just
run into something brand new
for you although i wonder what were you
thinking here were you thinking about
only this plan or other plans as well
yeah i was thinking most about f4 and
knight f3 but
um i haven't thought that okay i guess
c5
but i also was a little bit
uncomfortable with the idea of bishop a6
because like this immediately
or just later after like something like
this
no like immediately i believe
because like i can't stop c5 that is
pretty obvious
and i've expanded so much and i tell
that if i don't have an initiative on
the king's side you know i in the long
run it won't be very pleasant after c5
so i think you're a little bit
overestimating the c5 because like let's
say you take take here or wherever i
would i like your idea because you will
eventually have this idea but here
the problem with black structure
is that it's bad if you push and it's
bad if you take like you take and you
can be worse as white yeah there's no
way you're worse and even if they
somehow trade off the f pawn
you'll have that extra space and to push
on that that side of the board yeah
however there's no rush to either take
or perceive for but on the other hand
eventually you might
just take on c5
yeah and that is also true so i think um
there's like no big danger for you i'm
not saying that you're necessarily
better
but i feel that uh
i don't think is as dangerous but i mean
i respect
your way of thinking
c5 knight e2 knight c6 f4
bishop c2 just over defending yeah
i wasn't happy with what happened here
so bishop c to bishop f and yeah now
it's actually getting dicey
yeah
castles
takes and apparently that was a mistake
and this is what i'm telling you that um
um
one of the key in this position is
whoever can retain the pressure longer
yeah i was a little bit concerned about
bishops takes e2 and online
and you hide
yeah some some
yeah
this wasn't yeah this is very happy this
is not
it's not my dream position yeah it's not
your dream position but i think you're
still in the game for sure i am in the
game but
yeah it's
it's just unpleasant yeah it's annoying
because
your opponent has an easy plan yeah it
feels much easier to play as black
plus she has a whole lot more time
so
it's
yeah yeah we can see the things yeah
wrong well okay
i mean it's never easy to actually face
a novelty or something that's new for
you and then come up with the best
response
but for that like
he she definitely could have get the
better yeah
chances here with taking but ctx is just
shows and that's actually the problem
when you play multiple openings that you
might not know all the details
that here for example you need the
tension well her position is still very
active so i guess she overestimated it
yeah i mean um but not the d-pawn is
going to be eternally yeah how that is
so i was very surprised by c takes d4
c takes d4 is clearly not a good
movement this is the very rare occasion
i agree with the computer assessment
there
takes
knight c6 queen f2 which is fine like
you want to have your pieces next to
each other
like even if the computer wants queen a4
i don't see the point exactly therefore
it didn't even cross mine
i think that's a very bad practical
movie you might just be lost there
with b5 maybe the computer finds a way
to survive but i mean for a human like
you can i just didn't even yeah no i
mean i think you did the right thing put
the king into safety f6 so far all very
logical
e6 of course you don't want anything to
open up yeah and here i was
very puzzled by queen d6 i expected
something like queen
e7 or just to move the queen away
and i figured i would have to play
knight e2
takes e6 takes on d4
and yeah i thought
this is it
it's even like maybe this one's a little
weak but so is the b-pawn yeah so i very
much expected this to happen in the game
and when she played queen d6 it was like
oh she's playing for a win yeah
which is very logical since i have a lot
less time and
she should try to pressure me yeah f5
but allowing f5 yeah it's very dicey
it's very very dicey here so f5
rook c8
a3
and i mean
okay i don't know why like uh
they're so harsh on it apparently i
guess just wanting to bring the computer
just wants to bring the knight and the
rook in
yeah but i just wanted to prevent ideas
without before
like
i feel and i'll be honest here the
computers are just way too harsh for no
reason like yeah yeah yeah there's not
knight before no biggie rook c2 that's
not a problem you're not gonna get made
it like okay
of course with the computer you have a
fun time so yeah sure this is nothing
there's no problem right um yeah totally
i don't want to play that with less than
10 minutes there is absolutely zero
chance whoa
eric rosen thank you so much for rating
and hello everyone we're at the
gm norm congress we're talking with
gabby antova
who's actually showing her a very nice
game against tokyo genova
so
in this position
i think you made the right choice of
going e3 i just thought it was very
practical no this is a good move uh the
computer is just being arrogant
a3 rook d8 rookie one knight t7 and the
computer is probably like complaining
that you're not giving the biggest
advantage or like getting the biggest uh
and the best moves but now you're again
i was pretty sure i wasn't playing the
best of moves but i wanted to stay in
the game to be fair i mean as long as
you're safe i mean it like in chess and
then driving safety first
yeah i also tell that 97 is a little bit
passive yeah yeah i tell that some ideas
with 95 and d3 will be scarier and
that's what i was thinking mainly in the
game yeah and you're correct 95 would
have been better so 97 knight e4
g4
d3
rogue d2 and uh
yeah i
i'm sorry computer
like i get it you'd love to take the
pawn but i mean
point that the first super gm who take
that b6 one and it's like uh i'm not
gonna get mated
yeah well it was a leap of fate on the
next move yeah i eventually took it yeah
yeah
so rook d2 rook c4
but there's like a big difference go
ahead no like a rook c4 i didn't really
like but i wasn't sure what to do
against rook c6 just protecting the
sexes yeah the same ideas
i guess you could just go rook e3 and
just try to gobble the pawn yeah but
it's definitely different than what
happened in the game because after queen
b6 i start to have threats on my own
just along the seven rank
and
yeah i guess it's still annoying
roxy six g maybe rook c6 and g5 and
that's
but maybe you can take it's hard to make
it work because rook c6 like also um
attacking
yeah you just take this
so yeah
that makes a lot of sense
in any case rook c4 was played but uh i
kind of like this is something that i
could get behind more because
that rugby it isn't just
attacking you in front yeah like this on
happening so it takes eight six so let's
fast forward towards the end around here
here instead of me and dorothea were
like king a2 just you know rook d3 is a
good move but it's very dangerous
especially when you're low on time and
this is one of those things i noticed in
your games
that you sort of refuse to gain that
extra 30 seconds when you really should
be doing that
yeah i don't know how to explain it just
uh during those positions when i'm low
on time she's still i mean i'm clearly
better but she still has pressure so i'm
so nervous that
i don't really believe in those moves
but i definitely advise you to sort of
look for these moves especially if you
have a position of strength like this to
look for
not that committal moves your advantage
is still huge after king a2
and after like you play a couple of
these moves you get like you'll be on
two minutes
and then you can go rogue d3 i agree
does
i should have definitely done that
because now it was very very scary
and even though you're winning
by
by the smallest of margins
it could have gone
any of the way
yes that definitely wasn't smooth at all
and it's
like so ridiculous because i'm up so
much material and i'm there panicking
whether my cake will be made
but
let me be honest with you then you start
defending very very well
uh just you didn't have to go here and
get there
so here check knight c5 is great rook c3
here
um
yeah and in general i wasn't fond of a4
like if yeah possible that should have
been avoided but then knight b3 was
great queen c5 the other move i really
like that dorsa was like
saying play queen e2 like all the time
these moves are the best especially when
you're up material
over defend your pieces
and then go
have your second threat and that's
actually what you do afterwards so we're
just gonna quickly wrap this up
then you still make the right moves
um
yeah just uh when i'm low on time i have
this problem that i really start to just
defend and i'm not really looking for my
own play and here even though that i'm
so much you know better i still defend
like i'm trying to reflect over threats
which is
well
it's good to be sure that you're safe
but you sometimes have to look for your
poinsettia for of course after e7 you're
winning and i take sticks and thank you
that was so really good yeah
so we got to this point honestly i think
i know that you're not necessarily happy
with your result but i think you played
good chess
overall quality wise which is one of
those things that people don't often
look at
that you were having
good positions and then time trouble got
to you
yeah i thought i was playing fine up
until some point to the games but
at the end i was always slow on time and
then a lot of blunders came
i blundered probably like in three or
four games just hang up a piece in one
move and this shouldn't be happening at
that level which was very frustrating
and uh later on it made me question my
decisions because you know when you
hang pieces like this you don't have the
best of confidence
yeah i agree with that but one last
advice before i let you go is that
don't forget your opponent is also
nervous when they're like down so many
pawns are like a bad position i'm not
necessarily thinking about the begging
game or playing beg him but in a lot of
your games just know that hey my
opponent is just as nervous as i am
especially sometimes in your time
trouble yeah i i could see that i just
had struggle controlling my my own
emotions i know it's overwhelmed
but in any case thank you for popping in
and
have a great tournament in chicago thank
you thank you for having me so
we actually have results
so
let me
just
mention so postuma actually won the
event clear first
uh with grabinsky grabbin
number two spot
um in the im section and i said before i
really like possuma's play um there are
very shaky moments but he's been
coasting with white
being
fairly
stable
and i see no reason
why we shouldn't see him
on a higher
section meaning i am to gm but here we
have joshua and i'm gonna ask him are
you ready for the gm section
yes
yes i would love to play in the gm
section next time if i get invited back
yeah okay all right so
um
organizers you know what to do
joshua get ready and get prepared okay
because you really have to get prepared
man you get thrown in to that deep water
yes
so let's start from the beginning first
off congratulations for winning the
event thank you and um i also want to
ask you about your feelings
how did you approach this game
um
yeah i mean i didn't
have a lot to lose of course i i needed
to either draw or win to win the
tournament um which is of course nice
and uh but my main goal i already had
accomplished right getting that final
norm um so i
you know i was gonna play for the win
um
and
yeah i don't know
so
um
oh so we're playing for the win okay so
that's a great mindset to have yeah a
lot of players just go like oh i already
won i don't want to do anything anymore
you just play by or be here
right but no the right attitude is to
play and c maybe we can score even more
points and you don't want to have the
mindset of playing for a draw right i
usually tell like students don't do that
you'll end up compromising and yeah
that's not what you want
so knight c3 takes takes knight f6 this
is uh topical
knight takes bishop e6 and i've seen
this from alex slenderman yeah that's
where i first saw it as well okay so
we're on the same page yep yeah and the
computer isn't but it will be in a
moment queen e6 bishop e6
c4 okay where are you familiar with this
move c4 a little bit yep yep i faced it
online a couple of times
um i it is i think one of the more the
critical lines one of the one of the
better tries for white
um i i was out of prep at this point so
i was just uh having to rely on uh
my my memory
but the plan here for black is pretty
straightforward it's to go knight d7
knight f6
and
um mind if i explain the bishop e6 move
a little bit because it looks very
strange right it does it does it's
something we advise young children not
to watch or see
yes yes you almost never want to block
in your center pawn with with your
bishop like that but um the point is
that i want to ultimately get the bishop
outside of the pawn chain
and if you tried to go with knight d7
and knight f6 right away
there your bishop will oftentimes end up
getting stuck inside the pawn chain you
know the line with uh where you attack
the queen but then 95 and they threaten
mates yeah yeah so uh yeah that's a good
one let's just show for people from all
kinds of channels by the way you're
watched by hikaru fans i am rosen fans
chess dojo fans possuma fans fantastic
so
um
knight f6 queen e2 and if you're like
hey i want to play this line then hey
you might just get checkmated so this is
a double no-no it kind of closes in the
bishop on c8 and the king on e8 yes also
not to mention because
uh xqc fans are also cheering for you
apparently okay great great so knight d6
and
it's mate and also you mistreated your
bishop how dare you
yeah so the other thing is if you trade
the knights and then go knight d7 and
maybe you can just quickly show that
line yeah which one you will after queen
e2 knight takes e4 queen takes e4 bit
knight d7 uh bishop c4 knight f6
white plays 95 in this position and you
know you have you have to appreciate
ladies but not this one because then you
get checkmated right so you know treat
the ladies wisely otherwise punishment
will be swift
good life lesson yes
uh so anyways that's part of the reason
i that's the
bishop e6 approach better bishop e6 yeah
it's basically getting this bishop out
this is kind of like the
big trouble uh in any sort of position
with black what to do with the bishop so
that's what joshua is solving
c4 knight d7 knight f6 let's just move
forward i guess you don't want to go g6
because of immediate bishop h6 yeah
ideas such as that and then a knight
coming to g5 at some point it seemed
like white would be set up perfectly for
a king side attack
so actually one of the reasons this
would be dubious if you play it and now
joshua is that it slows down the
castling
so you can't push the pawn because it's
illegal i'll show you
it doesn't let me it would even make
sound if it would be turned on it
doesn't let you so that's why
joshua made sure he could put the bishop
on f5 and this will be legal see it's
legal e6 i'll make it myself it's legal
so now the bishop is outside the chain
and now you can go castle
castles bishop e7 were you happy with
this when you saw this um yeah i i
thought i was uh uh fairly comfortable
here it seems like white's going to have
to spend a lot of time running their
queen around they've already spent three
moves with the queen yeah and now
they're going to have to spend even more
time with the queen meanwhile i've got
pretty natural development now and i'm
ready to castle yeah and if you people
didn't get what he meant
lots of queen moves not good
usually not good because uh it can run
into trouble like knight t4 trick you
sif you go
whistling about well hello there lady
you might get into trouble fairly
quickly
so for that very reason aaron moved his
queen away
castles
h3 a5 so sometimes people go age six
just to preserve but i guess you're not
afraid of knight h4 no so the reason i
wasn't afraid of that is i have the c2
square
that i can go to and which is looks kind
of funny but it's actually kind of
annoying
to put the bishop there and it's not so
easy for white to kick it out you know
queen d2 of course is like not a move
white wants to play because it just
blocks in their bishop
and i assume you're going towards there
and not the side yes i don't want to get
trapped i would probably go to e4 so
that
so let's you know educate
the people here the reason we usually
put pieces in the middle instead of the
side
on the side everything gets trapped
really quickly like this bishop just
gets trapped like on the spot
um but if you put stuff in the middle
they don't get trapped and more often
than not you can escape
you have a lot more squares that you can
move to from the center yeah from the
edge in fact like it multiplies from
there
way more square than you could go
from there ever and this knight like it
barely can only go this square so that's
like a perfect example look at this
bishop can go with all these squares
this knight only this one otherwise it's
gonna get taken on f5 and g6 yeah
ergo don't put your pieces on the side
of the board
you think they're going to learn i i
think so all right good so d1 bishop c2
so i guess this is something that you
were looking forward to anyways yeah
just you know annoy his rook i don't
think he wants to go to d2 and block in
his bishop and i also don't think he
wants to go back to e1 so yeah bishop c2
is a very nice little
uh annoying move to make rookie one
queen b6
again it's just probing moves
the fact is that white is also solid
it's very difficult to actually win
those pawns but now the bishop cannot
move and believe it or not that's sort
of like the opposite of the bishop on c8
yeah and especially in this case because
white has spent so much time moving the
queen around
yeah so queen e3 rook d8
sometimes
giving a space for this bishop how did
you decide on rook d8 though
did you consider going this way
not really no i i just thought i wanted
to pressure the d4 pawn
uh since white's pushed their c pawn up
to c4 it means the d4 pawn can't be
defended by a by a pawn anymore so it's
uh you know it's an easy target by
playing rook d8 i can stop knight e5
yeah right
um and i wanted to keep the other rook
on a8 because
it could be useful on the a file after
a4 and there are lines where the a file
could open up right yes a rook d8 yeah
sometimes i like rook e8 if it's a bit
more defensive because then you over
protect the bishop you move away and you
also target this lady on e3
okay but i mean rook d8 is also very
normal and your line of thinking makes a
lot of sense
because you're sort of trying to play
for the initiative more rookie is
somewhat more defensive bishop d3 aaron
feels the heat tries to get rid of that
bishop but that you know more trades in
this position means it's just getting
more equal
a4
gaining a little space on the sides
between c2 queen a6
so many typical karakon ideas i guess
you may even consider b5 exactly yeah so
here b5 here it is
b5
attacking this and by the way um i'm not
here to explain if you have something to
add or you want
if you want to jump on in please please
feel free to do so sure so
i will say about b5 that um
that's unfortunate but we're gonna get
back
yeah to the position at hand i wanted to
say that i'm i'm playing like what i
call a light square strategy right i'm
trying to uh to take full control over
the light squares i'm putting pawns on
light squares
and the point of b5 is to try to
undermine white's control of the d5
square so i can get that really nice
outpost for my knight
yeah very sound strategy
takes rook b8 saying okay if you take
this i take you and that's a fair trade
i mean fairer for black
than fair yes we have this trade not
only is there a target on a2 but there
is also this juicy square on the yes
so
queen c2 knight d5
a3
rook b5 just going for double one
doubles bishop f6
97 yeah here's where i feel like i i
started to to lose the threat a little
bit uh i thought his plan of dropping a
bishop back to c1 as passive as it looks
was actually really smart because it
means it doesn't matter how many major
pieces i stack up on the b file his
b-pawn will be safe yeah that never be
captured although i'm still still kind
of more critical of bishop on c1 that
yes it's passive
but
if you're this passive
the chances of you winning the game is
minimal after that so
sometimes like i believe that uh
like super gm3 really want to win they
go knight c4 activate the bishop and
hope for the best yeah because with this
bishop on c1 it just
is on the lowest value it can get
that's true not that it's not useful
here
knight f5
takes
yes so i gave up a pawn yeah you gave up
a pawn why did you do such a thing
i don't know well no i do um
i honestly i wasn't sure how to proceed
with the position uh with his b2 pawn
being well defended i figured i should
try to switch to the second weakness in
the position uh which was attacking the
uh the d4 pawn
um
and i yeah and if i didn't go knight f5
i wasn't really sure what else to do we
can go back one move yeah instead of
knight f5 uh i was also thinking about
rook d5 instead uh-huh
um
yeah yeah uh
was something i didn't like about that
uh oh knight g4 yeah that is annoying
yeah because the bishop is trapped once
that is exchanged you might get slightly
worse yeah well especially if i have to
take back with the pawn oh yeah that
would be really bad sometimes you would
even play weird moves like broken
yeah but already you would be like this
is sort of like an easter egg position
what is the rook doing there right and
there's bishop g5 at the end yeah
and then the c6 pawn falls so anyways i
just wasn't really sure how else to
proceed i kind of like that move you're
sort of switching gears and says no no
no i'm not going to defend passively so
you know i don't want to compliment you
too much but carlson does love doing
this when he says okay i'm getting too
passive i'd rather give up upon get some
counter play and make my opponent work
for it yes and i did also think that by
him taking the pawn he is opening the c
file for me which i'll take full control
of and he has to worry about me
infiltrating to the co2 square yeah and
all the banco fans if they're lurking
around they know that hey i'm down upon
but if you give me full control of files
and pressure on the queen side that's
way more than enough i'm a i'm a former
benko player myself
so i already knew that this is great for
you yes
so see that's why you learn different
openings and not stick to the boredom i
mean london
so g4 knight d6 rookie 2 h6 just solid
and that's actually a good mindset to
have if you know you have compensation
you don't necessarily have to go for a
broke
so king f1 takes
rook takes knight c4 here and rooks if i
really didn't like i think he really had
to go rookie 2 and try to go d5 i mean
i'm pretty sure you wanted to go here
oh that yeah that's one approach um i
was also thinking i could just try to
win my pawn back by force with rook v8
and i was calculating maybe you could
play this out rook b8 d5
takes rook takes knight takes bishop
takes rick takes rick takes takes he can
go rook d4 but i have rook b3 and when
he takes on a4 i can take on h3 yeah so
i'm not going to be down upon i'll be
honest with you we talked a similar
position with dorsa with the pawn on f4
but even if you don't win the h pawn you
just go
wherever
like this is still a dead draw cause
white's king is just way too passive
this king has to be on e3 to hope for a
win even that is objectively drawn but
that there are practical chances of
winning here with the king cut off and
it will always be cut off
no hope whatsoever so i think
that's true yeah well calculated and
yeah i kind of agree and that's
that's also what we thought so takes
knight c4 i don't like rook c5 but
obviously you have to do something
takes rook c7 takes
f5
takes 6 g5
and yeah i mean you're just having a
great control unfortunately for aaron
there's knight e5 check
which is of course an important little
detail
so even if you have a good position you
still have to look out for cheapos i was
thinking he would go for this though and
after king d4
uh i don't think i want to trade the
rooks and give him a past pawn with his
king being so active my plan was rook b5
uh i was also contemplating rook a5 but
you know maybe here he could check on c8
and go to a8
and
try to pick off the yeah that point
although
you're so active i doubt that this
should be objectively too much
yeah in any case h4 was played but
that's sort of forcing more trades which
of course you're not unhappy or that
yeah i said at the beginning i was gonna
try to play for a win but i was going to
be perfectly content with the draw yeah
so you know if at this point if we just
trade all the pawns
and have a draw that's that's totally
fine with me so let's just fast forward
the last one here boom it takes b2
even if you got a very nice technical
position sometime tactics can make your
life much easier after check check you
take here and you're fine
here check
takes and with
all these pieces traded
actually
you could be the one pushing but not
really
um
and you're just holding it all very
smoothly
very nice very nice job
uh g3 takes trades
and uh the game ended in a draw after
the king d3 move so joshua
great tournament
hope to see some more of that great
chess
solid but very exciting chess
keep on going and i really want to see
you in the gm section and don't
disappoint please
okay all right absolutely i would love
to come back and play in the gm section
and uh start working towards uh the gm
title yeah yeah and with that we are
going to take a look at the standings
and joshua thank you so much for coming
and congrats again thank you dennis
so we've got
the gm section
up there
with the final result after round nine
we've got vladimir belush with seven and
a half points at a nine
very smoothly coasting towards the
finish line there were some exciting
games some exciting kings indians but he
really never seemed to be in any danger
and even solid openings felt like a
breeze for him even the petrov that he
played with black felt like a winning
opening
now balaji actually had a much less
favorable time he was doing quite well
but it was kind of painful for
uh him to lose in the last game but what
a game that was dorsa i see yeah that
was definitely a birthday king oh that
was a cool that was the
sacrifice and
if if my intel is correct you might see
more of that game in some lesson in the
future by the gm in residence now you
may not know who the gm in residence is
it's probably that akshani
that's my guess thank you thank you we
might be looking at that a little bit in
depth today because i want to really
talk about queen sacrifice later today
and some of the fun lectures that we'll
have for you so talking about fun games
and fun results let's take a look at the
i am section
so dorsa can you tell us what happened
here well i see that the last game was
the the draw was a very
breathtaking one so we got joshua and
aaron's huge congratulations to joshua
he was right in
before me and he got his in title
wonderful
and also pocketed twelve hundred dollars
and
aaron got
second wait no question the second or
third would they be sharing the price
then uh yeah they're sharing the price
it's uh shared second place just like in
the previous one it was a shared second
place interesting and then we have
jennifer eu
for the fourth place which is
respectable and it was kind of fun
she was just outside we were chatting
and we were just talking she has five i
am worms wow that's a lot of i am norms
but honestly jennifer was playing very
well and so was beckham yeah i felt that
the ladies were doing quite well this
event
and even though
on the bottom half you see gabriella i
felt that objectively it's not that she
had bad positions and not that she
wasn't in contention in each of the
games it really was the time trouble
but again if she learns how to handle uh
time better i think
i'll be sure to enjoy the message to her
yeah again
ellis lee was playing well yeah
and this was her first time in the i am
section here very talented young lady
and
i'll definitely be looking forward to
seeing her grow and becoming
maybe a some part of our olympic team
yeah um no question about it so with
that first of let's congratulate the
winners congratulations to grandmaster
vladimir blush for 2k
clean 2k nice no doubts about it there's
taxes
let's not ruin the party so early dorsa
so 2k for baloch
well done for
the young grandmaster and also last but
not least
joshua postuma well the fm title will
now i am elected as he is going to get
the i am title and uh
that's a lot of money and someone's
asking me where's the hat well probably
can sponsor a lot of hat by now so i'm
looking forward to that one joshua and
uh that's really all folks
we have the two winners vladimir and
joshua
and tarsa this has been a fun ride
exactly it's been a pleasure being here
it was a pleasure doing comments
pleasure
and hopefully we can do this again in
the future
soon enough
and i hope all of you enjoyed your time
here hikaru fans
we held you rosen fans we held you i was
just about to say chess dojo fans we
hailed you we had a lot of fun joe bruen
i see you in the chat
but we've got to wave our final goodbyes
bye bye thank you for having us
[Music]
been a presentation of the st louis
chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited
you